the chairman's chaplain and the chief
executive
good evening members
um
may i introduce reverend kim
who is my local vicar down in barley
that covers a number of areas
from rochford through to barley to great
wakering
ashington
has a number of churches and
it's going to do prayers for us thank
you
first and foremost i'd like to say how
privileged and honoured i am to have
been invited to be mike's at chaplin
and i will be seeing you and be assured
of my prayers for all of you
not just tonight but ongoing as you lead
the people of the rochford district so i
will say three very short prayers the
middle is the lord's prayer
if it's your tradition and you'd like to
join in with me please do feel free to
do that
so let us pray
god of justice and mercy we thank you
for the gift of life and the opportunity
to serve the people of the rochford
district
as we begin this meeting help us to act
with character and conviction
to listen with understanding and
goodwill
to speak with charity and restraint give
us a spirit of service
and remind us that we are stewards of
your authority
guide us to be the leaders the people of
the rochford district need
help us to see the humanity and dignity
of those who disagree with us
and to treat all persons with the
reverence your creation deserves
and finally father renew us with the
strength of your presence and the joy of
helping to build a community worthy of
all persons
we ask this as your children
confident in your goodness and love
amen
the lord's prayer
our father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come
thy will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
and lead us not into temptation but
deliver us from evil for thine is the
kingdom the power and the glory forever
and ever
are men
so a final blessing
in darkness and in light
in trouble and in enjoy
help us heavenly father to trust your
love
to serve your purpose and to praise your
name
through christ our lord
and the blessing of god almighty the
father the son and the holy spirit
be with you
and all whom you love
this night and forevermore
amen
thank you very much you are more than
welcome to stay if you wish but i do
know you have a very busy schedule god
bless you thank you thank you very much
god bless have a good meeting
be seated
okay
so
members
uh just a couple of items to
mention before we get started
when i invite you to speak
there are microphones at both ends of
the row on which you are seated
please wait
until you have the microphone in front
of you before speaking
if you prefer there is also a microphone
and a lectern from which you are welcome
to speak
when i invite you to speak
all microphones are switched on ready to
speak
so you do not need to adjust them
however can i ask you
to speak clearly and directly into the
microphone
when i invite you to speak
given the size of the room
and the numbers of us present
when you wish to speak or vote
can you please raise your hand clearly
high in the air
like you used to do at school
so that you could be easily seen by all
and leave it up until i ask you to lower
it
members
you've all had some guidance
on points of order
which have been circulated to you all
and i would ask that if you have any
points of order
to raise during the meeting
you should provide the reference to the
relevant part of the constitution
agenda item one
apologies
i have apologies from councillor
constable councillor john mason
councillor wilkinson
are there any others
members are there any
any declarations of interest
okay just to remind you if anything
comes up during the course of the
meeting please make it known at that
time
item three
i will now invite the council chief
executive mr jonathan stevenson to
introduce the report to the revised pay
policy statement for 2022 stroke 23.
thank you chairman
members you have a copy of the pay
policy statement in front of you um it's
a revision to the statement that you
received in february this year it's part
of the journey of the partnership with
the with brett mcborough council
we need a pay policy statement that
aligns so we can have equal pay across
the partnership
happy to take any comments on the
statement if required thank you
counselor mr hoy
thank you chairman um
i think members may remember i did query
the pay policy statement
um in january around the equality and
diversity
comments where it said
rather than it
make a difference um i've had
communication before this meeting with
the chief executive jonathan stevens
stevenson around this
and
i felt that the explanation he
gave me
around the reason why it does say should
he's very clear very concise and
gives a proper understanding of what we
do
i felt that it was appropriate to
include
some of the wording that he used in his
email to me to insert as an amendment
into the equality and diversity section
of the report so it gives
a full account of why it should and
a background of the other things that we
do to make sure it our equipment
diversity within the pay policy
does make a difference and does make
sure we take account of
gender and
other
other
issues
if i'm okay to read this out
this is slightly amended from the
paragraph because it was a
personally now it referred to my age
that's just before you do can i ask you
to turn your microphone a little bit
closer so it's picking picking you up
tip it up slightly okay
yep that's it
that's cool is that better
thank you thank you
um
so this is for insertion within the
equality and diversity section of the
report
the equality impact statement within
this report is based wholly on the pay
policy statement not
all of
not all of the other factors within the
pay and remuneration process for our
employees
there are other factors such as
recruitment job evaluation working
arrangements open brackets part time
oblique full time closed brackets etc
this is why the statements say should or
not will this is because the statement
on its own cannot fulfill this
commitment
the council will always endeavor to pay
and remunerate our employees fairly and
the pay policy statement is one
mechanism to ensure this happens and
hence why it is reviewed annually
that is the
comments made by jonathan stephenson and
they're the ones i'm recommending for
inclusion in the
okay
as an amendment counselor
yes thank you
councillor
thank you mr chairman
makes a very good point uh in respect of
the pay policy and i'm very happy to
second his proposal thank you
anybody else wish to speak on this
i can't see who he is
councilman cross
um thank you chairman under uh
additional payments for po20 and below
um
section
four point one additional payments uh i
suspect across can i just stop you for a
second uh
we
you need to be speaking to the amendment
at the moment
so is this relevant to the
amendment uh no sorry okay all right
i'll come back to you when we've dealt
with the amendment thank you chairman
anybody else wish to speak to the
amendment
okay members
i'll put the amendment to you and
all those in favor if you can show with
your hands please
okay
blow your hands
any against
any abstentions
okay that is 35 4
none against no extensions
therefore the
amendment becomes part of the
substantive motion
council across if you wish to raise your
point
thank you chairman uh paul i apologize
members for my earlier uh mistimed
intervention um
under uh additional payments for po20 is
just a small point
i suspect the award in relation to
maintaining 100 attendance
may have been
written into the
structure before covid
and my question really is should we be
awarding people to
attend their place of work
and give them a payment for attendance
when the tendency may be to attend if
they're not feeling too good and may
indeed have covid so it's just a concern
really that we're rewarding people who
may actually be ill
to turn up for work thank you chairman
mr savisa do you want to pick up on a
point
thank you chairman thank you councillor
cross um with regard to the the
statement you've got in front of you at
4.1 is that area of the statement is
exactly the same as the the policy that
came in february um the statement you've
got in front of you now picks up the
first three tiers of the organization
and you raise a good point that that
area of the pace policy statement
doesn't need looking at and reviewing
moving forward especially when we look
to align grades down from p20 down so
it's something that we'll take into
account um because obviously what we
wouldn't want to do if we're looking to
combine um workforces as one have
different terms of consistent different
arrangements i'm not obtaining
commitment that will leave the pay
policy that will come back to members
but we need to review to make sure that
that people's terms get different terms
and conditions and arrangements are the
same if we work as one team across two
councils
but that's a good point it will be
reviewed so
anybody else wish to speak
okay right
members we have one recommendation set
out in at paragraph 7.1
of the report on page 3.3
the pay policy statement an appendix one
be adopted
including the amendment that we've just
agreed
i will move the recommendation
from the chair do i have a second
members
with the show of hands
those in favor
okay please lower your hands
those against
any abstentions
thank you members that is unanimous
okay members agenda item four
i will now invite councillor lovely
leslie butcher chairman of the audit
committee to introduce the report
council butcher
can you hear me
members as chair of the council's audit
committee i present this report to you
which seeks council approval to create a
shared internal audit service with
basildon borough council
from the 1st of july this year
it is proposed that this is achieved
through a delegation of the council's
internal audit service to basildon
this is permissible under the local
government act 1972
basildon has already agreed to accept
this delegation at its full council
meeting on the 24th of march
and subject to the appropriate
governance being undertaken by this
council
and finalization of the supporting legal
agreement being signed by both councils
effective internal audit services have a
vital role to play in helping the
council achieve its objectives
by ensuring the soundness of governance
risk management and control arrangements
to remain effective in an increasingly
challenging environment
internal audit teams need to be able to
provide the necessary quality
depth and coverage of assurance
rochford currently has a small internal
audit team of two officers
supplemented by chief audit executive
support which is already provided by
basildon council
however due to the imminent retirement
of rochford's principal auditor
the councils had to reconsider options
for the delivery of its internal audit
services going forward
this report sets out the different
options considered
but recommends option three
a shared services solution is
implemented
this will have the advantage of enabling
the council to access a bigger pool of
experienced internal audit resources
and will provide greater resilience
across both councils
under the proposals the other current
rochford employee will troopy across to
basildon with effect from the first of
july if this is agreed
although rochford has already entered a
strategic partnership with brentford
borough council
brentwood are not able to join up
internal audit services at this time
as they are currently committed to an
external contract
however rochford has an existing
relationship with basildon borough
council to provide its chief auditor
function
which has worked very well over the past
few years
the proposed shared services is a
natural extension of that successful
relationship
and it has been very successful
going forward it may be an option for
brentwood borough council to also join
the shared service arrangement in future
but of course that will be up to them
under the proposal accountability for
the adequacy of internal audit will
remain firmly with the individual
councils
who will remain responsible for
fulfilling their obligations
and duties under the accounts and audit
regulations 2015.
each council will retain their own audit
committee
basildon borough council will recharge
for their time based on actual cost
incurred
it is anticipated that the annual cost
will be slightly less than rochford's
existing internal audit staffing budget
but this will be closely monitored going
forward
i therefore propose that the
recommendations set out at paragraph 8.1
of the report
are
agreed if you have any questions i will
be happy to answer these
i'll refer
to uh
to neo to our officer naomi lucas who's
our 151 officer
thank you
thank you council butcher do you have a
second
council gary myers
council high
chairman as you know i can't resist
anything
other than to talk about audit sometimes
um i was a bit concerned when i saw this
as a key decision because it did occur
to me why we weren't linking more with
brentwood given that was the direction
we were appearing to be going in but the
report does set that out very clearly
and it does make a lot of sense i have
been on the audit committee
in previous years
and i felt that basildon have
been very good to us they've
helped her under helped with their
understaffing um
and have done a very good job with jim
and i i was very surprised to see
jimmy's retirement age i didn't realize
he was that old and he's proved good
service in the past
um the only question i've really got or
concerned is that
counselor butcher mentioned
that the
cost would be
slightly under
our budgeted
cost for internal audit i know that
we've always struggled to fill our
internal audit roles and i'm not sure
that
i just want clarity over whether that's
a
battery cost of our full staffing or the
budgeting cost of whatever actual
staffing
is and i don't think this is something
that we should be too worried about
spending a proper budget on because it
is very important to the organisation
thank you
anybody else
counselor mrs wilson
uh hello chair thank you
um my question is actually posed to an
officer
for yourself if that's okay thank you
i'm reading this this report and i just
had concerns not necessarily on the fact
that there is the possibility that we
might make 14 000 pounds worth of
savings but i wondered if a cost ceiling
um was going to be put on top of this
on top of the budget already and
expected to to spend that that was my
first point and my second point mainly
to the officer is um who will monitor
the work that bazillion council does i'm
assuming it will come back to the audit
committee for us to have a look at and
at what time scale is that likely to
happen because in the uh in the report
there's nothing about feedback and
how we would action that thank you
thank you councilman wilson
mrs darling
um thank you members
um okay
just just to answer councillor hoy's um
point which was also linked to the
second point i think about costs um
so yeah we haven't um
deliberately set a budget which is under
our current budget if you like the sort
of deliverable number of audit hours is
um consistent with what we have in our
current internal audit plan obviously
we're anticipating there will be some
slight efficiencies through the joint
working which should um you know result
in small savings for the council
um but as i say the actual deliverable
number of hours will be equivalent and
actually some of our current principal
auditor's time is actually spent on sort
of non-direct audit work if you like
including some sort of assurance work
and i did
allude to in the report that actually we
may have to cover some of that other
work that he does through other means so
some of that um sort of spare budget
capacity might have to be redirected to
um to cover some of that
um
but in terms of um the actual costs are
recharged um to us from basildorn um
yeah there isn't an absolute cap um but
they are going to charge us on a cost
across basis so they're not actually
making
a profit if you like out of the
arrangement
and essentially it comes down to sort of
um
looking at the various risks of
different options and if and even if we
were to go out and sort of um
try and recruit our own auditor there's
no guarantee that we would be able to
sort of create the resource at a
particular um level or cost so i think
we have to just accept that um yeah that
the cost will be managed effectively by
um basildon and we'll obviously monitor
that throughout the year but yeah so i
can't give you an absolute guarantee
that it won't exceed the cost that's in
the report but based on the number of
hours they're expecting to provide i
would expect it to be roughly equivalent
to the cost set out in the report
um i hope that makes sense um in terms
of the um reporting um
sort of and um kpi responsibility if you
like
um yeah ultimately a section 151 officer
i will still be accountable for making
sure that the internal audit plan is
delivered for the council and overseeing
the work that bazeldon does but
obviously that will be
subject to the same scrutiny that it is
through audit committee at the moment
and so audit committee will continue to
receive quarterly update reports
um
on the work that the um the service is
providing so i hope that provides the
assurance that you're looking for
okay are you happy that council mrs
wilson
is coming from totally it just always
bothers me there's no ceiling on
expenditure
um i've worked in organizations where
including with audits actually where it
doesn't take too much to ramp the costs
up quite significantly that that was my
concern but if the office is happy with
that
then then i'm happy with that okay i'm
sure the officer will take that on board
councillor ian foster
chairman just a small point of
clarification please on four point page
4.3
the last bullet point in item 3.4 talks
about
commercial
opportunities and my question is
would that be of benefit to rochester
district council or would it just be of
benefit to
baseline council
do you want to respond
yeah thank you um
i think that points um yeah alluding to
the fact that um yeah this shared
service arrangement is obviously between
from um sorry president and rochford at
the moment but um as we said in the
report there may be opportunity for
other
um
councils potentially to join that um so
we've said that brentwood may consider
that in the future possibly um and
there's a possibility that other
councils may wish to
join that arrangement in future as well
um so i think that's what that point is
um alluding to really that we obviously
want to try and make efficiencies and
sort of manage it in a commercial way
as much as possible
back chairman obviously i didn't make my
question very clear i understand it
talks about commercial opportunities my
question was whether that would provide
financial benefit to rocha district
district council
out of those commercial opportunities
yeah so if there was commercial benefit
to the partnership in future um i think
it is a shared service and it is a sort
of collaborative arrangement so we'd
have to look at how those um
potential benefits would be shared
across the partnership we haven't sort
of specifically set out at this stage
but um
yeah i think that would be open to
negotiation with
okay any other members
council mr sharp
uh can you wait for the michael i'll
thank you i'm sorry
start i just want to ask whether there's
any indication here
with our external auditor
and where the bazaar borough council
have the same external order
thank you um
i don't think there's any um direct
implications um in terms of our external
audit arrangements and we currently have
ey
bazarden have bgos so they have a
different auditor
but
essentially the um work that the
external auditor does is completely
independent and historically the
external audit may have kind of placed
some reliance on the work of internal
audit but that's not really the case any
anymore so that they don't sort of um
yet place reliance on the evidence base
collected by internal audit during the
year they do all of their own work
independently so i don't think there's
any direct kind of read across if you
like um
between internal external audit that
would have an impact on on this
arrangement um
but just as a general point um
the
external audit arrangements with um
public sector appointments committee are
due to be returned in the next couple of
years anyway so we don't actually know
who our external auditor will be um in
the future anyway at this point after
the next year or so
um because that will be subject to that
arrangement
okay because sharp you're happy with our
response
anybody else
counselor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman through you could
i just ask the officer
um mr mason can you just bring your mic
a little closer please
i'm usually quite loud
can you hear me now that's much better
good
right
um through through you chairman i'd like
to ask the
officer on the recommendation 8.2
that the assistant director is being
authorized
assistant directors i should say be
authorised to approve the terms of the
joint working arrangement with effect
from the first of july 2022
how long is that agreement going to last
for i would expect there to be
a term an end date on it for renewal and
reassessment
thank you
through the sheriff that's all right
um
so
this arrangement is the kind of
sexual free arrangement is a kind of
delegated authority so in
in principle the arrangement will
continue until such time as council
agrees um it doesn't want it to continue
anymore but in practical terms um i
think what we've said is we will
obviously review it after the um first
year we're anticipating that the sort of
minimum um length of the agreement will
probably be three years but we will
handly review it um
but we there's no kind of set contract
if you like because it's not actually a
contractual arrangement it's a
delegation so it will continue as i say
until such time as either council
doesn't want it to continue
anymore
casual information follow up on that can
i just come back on that
um you've got the mic there still
it's right have you trouble hearing
again
yes
thank you for that that clarifies part
of it but is there any sort of notice
period that would have to be given
so i think if so what is it yes
thank you um
so again i suppose in
in formal kind of contractual terms
there's not a notice period as such
because it's not a contract but in
practical terms i think the service
level agreement or the joint working
agreement will state that it would be
fair and reasonable for us to give a
minimum of 12 months notice because in
practical terms it would take a little
while to unwind those arrangements and
so i think that's the kind of level of
time that we'd be talking about to
yeah make a change of policy on that
okay thank you for that clarity
anybody else
okay members
we have two recommendations set out in
paragraph 8.1 of the report on page 4.5
one that the council's
internal audit service be delegated to
basildon borough council
under sections 101
111
and 113 of the local government act 1972
and any other relevant
legislation
with effect from the first of july 2022
to the assistant director
resources in consultation with the
assistant director of legal and democrat
democrat
be authorized to approve the final terms
of the joint working arrangement and to
enter into all necessary and appropriate
contracts
and agreements to implement delivery
from the first of july 2022
members
the those recommendations have been
proposed and seconded
are you happy that i take them on block
members those in favor please indicate
thank you members like hans
that i'm advised is unanimous thank you
members
okay
members
that concludes the business of this
extraordinary meeting
and i declare the meeting closed at
2005
we will take a five minute comfort break
before we start the next extraordinary
meeting
thank you members
all right
could you please take your seats thank
you
don't mentioned
okay
good evening members
um been quite some time since our last
meeting
i think about 10 minutes
please bear with me i need to go through
the same procedures again
members when i invite you to speak there
are microphones at both ends of the row
on which you are seating sitting
please wait until you have one of the
microphones in front of you before
speaking
if you prefer there is also a microphone
electron for which you can
and are welcome to
speak when i invite you to speak
all microphones are switched on ready
for you to speak so you do not need to
adjust them
however can i ask you to speak clearly
and directly into the microphone when i
invite you to speak
given the size of the room and the
numbers of us present when you wish to
speak or vote can you please raise your
hand clearly and as i said as like when
you were at school
high in the air so joe can see
so it could be easily seen
and leave it up until you are asked to
know it
members guidance on points of water have
been circulated to you all
and i would ask that if you have any
points of order to raise during the
meeting
you should provide the reference the
reference relevant part of the
constitution
members item agenda item one apologies
for absence
uh councillor
roger constable councillor john mason
councillor wilkinson are there any
others
i don't think anybody's disappeared
during the interlude
okay
gender item 2 members are there any
declarations of interest
and again members i will remind you if
something comes up during the course of
the meeting please indicate clearly and
we will take that into account
gender item three
motions on notice
council newport
can you please introduce your motion on
notice
thank you chairman and um
thank you for this opportunity to bring
forward my uh our motion on notice
tonight after such a long time
um
i think the uh penny has sort of finally
dropped that we do have a a wide issue
with uh litter in our district and it's
been ongoing for
a very
okay
bring the microphone just a little
closer is that better yeah perhaps tip
it up a little bit more i don't know
is that better yeah
okay
thank you um
so
i think
uh
it's been well noted now that
the ongoing issue with litter in our
district has been ongoing for a
significant amount of time
um however
i find myself
with with my motion
that a litter strategy has now been put
forward to review
so on that basis uh chairman
i will um
work on review
um with the points that i make
we make in our motion
and take it forward through review for
recommendations back
to uh
the portfolio holder or council
respectively and uh on that basis i'll i
wish to withdraw this motion tonight
please
thank you councilman you paul thank you
that's quite easily done thank you
okay yeah
okay the second motion that we have on
notice
is
to be introduced by councillor
lisa newport
because of it is quite a lengthy one i i
am prepared to give just a little bit of
latitude in the time
for you to present it but please don't
run away with it uh during the course
and i will rein you in if necessary
thank you chair
please be mindful that the dates in the
motion in front of you are
different because obviously the motion
was first
to be put forward last year
this motion proposes that the council
actively supports a right for everyone
especially women and girls to be safe
from violence and harassment and will
commit to work in partnership with key
stakeholders as part of its wider
community safety approach
this motion calls on the council to
consolidate various initiatives and
publish a policy that gives information
and clarity to all so that our residents
can rest assured that the council is
doing its utmost to tackle violence
against women and girls and the
information to empower women and girls
to feel safe is both published promoted
and easily accessible
this council agrees the following
one believes everyone should have the
right to be safe from violence and
harassment on our streets
two recognizes that the killing of sarah
everard has again brought the issue of
behaviour towards women and girls and
their safety to the forefront
three
acknowledges it's not just women who are
at risk but that any individual may be
vulnerable to an attack for various
reasons
this council also notes
for there are already many excellent
initiatives and campaigns by local and
national organizations aimed at
safeguarding the welfare of individuals
for example got you back ask for annie
and the ask for angela scheme
five that this council is the only south
essex local authority to have a housing
option officer trained as an independent
domestic violence advocate
six violent incidents are thankfully
rare in the rochford district and our
police force already worked closely with
council officials to combat sexual
harassment and other types of aggression
seven
however every occurrence of intimidation
or attack is one too many
council therefore a result
resolutely rejects behavior and actions
which may cause women and girls from any
background to have to modify their
activities in order to feel safe
nine champions the right of women and
girls to be protected from violence and
harassment in public places within
rochford district
10 believes that the principle should be
embedded in our council strategies going
forward
eleven will actively support schemes
such as ask for angela and call on
licensed businesses to participate and
to take active steps to ensure
harassment and sexual intimidation is
taken seriously through participation in
this scheme
twelve calls on all council departments
and other bodies responsible for public
spaces for example housing associations
parish councils schools transport
providers to improve the security of
public spaces by encouraging them to
review lighting in streets car parks and
parks
cctv provision and other pertinent means
to improve safety
13. calls on schools colleges
universities and your youth
organizations to renew their efforts to
promote a safety and respect for all
agenda amongst their students
14. that the leader of rochford district
council ensures that white ribbon
accreditation is secured for the
organization and promote the wider
awareness of the accreditation in our
district
as part of this appoint a male
councillor as an ambassador
mark the white ribbon day
which is on
i don't think it's the 25th of november
now i think it's the 22nd of november
each year with a fundraising event and
encourage participation amongst council
staff and local primary and secondary
schools
15 we request an update on progress on
these matters to council in
six months
and councillors are reminded of their
public sector equality duty which
requires a council to consider or think
about how their policies or decisions
may affect people who are protected
under the equality act
i move this motion with the updated
dates
thank
do you have a second
counselor mrs mason
yes i would like to second the motion
but i will speak later thank you thank
you
councillor williams
thank you chairman
uh thank you for this motion um
i doubt that there are many members
organizations or indeed any other
councils in this country that would
disagree with the sentiments of this
motion
it goes without saying that this council
actively supports the right for everyone
especially women and girls to be safe
from violence and harassment on our
streets
the safety of our residents is paramount
there is currently a lot of work going
on nationally and locally to progress
this agenda
officers currently sit on a newly formed
county-wide safety advisory group and i
am a member of the safer ethics board
and what i have learned from this board
is that it is key we make sure
that all partners have shared awareness
about what we are all doing
as lots of projects are underway
in addition the joint castle point and
rochard community safety partnership
which i currently hold the position of
vice chairman
has recently adopted violence against
women and girls
as a standing agending a gender item
so that regular updates are received and
actions to follow
however there should be no jump to
solutions and all county partners have
agreed
we should understand what essex looks
like and understand what the findings
are from the police insight data which
is currently underway
in the meantime we continue as a council
to support all those projects that come
through the centre of this central board
as a portfolio holder for safety
i fully support this motion but would
like to propose that it be enhanced by
not only noting its contents but giving
our ongoing commitment
to continue to work in partnership with
all responsible bodies
including the county-wide safety
advisory group safer essex partners and
local community safety network in order
to achieve the objectives set out in
this motion
and report on on progress to the review
committee at the time of the community
safety partnerships annual update
thank you chairman
councillor williams uh do you have a
center
i would like to second castle
thank you chairman um i hope
i wholeheartedly agree with your motion
counselor mrs newport
and the
um
update from councillor arthur williams
and hopefully everybody's in agreement
if we can enhance that in any way it's
got to be good for everyone thank you
very much chairman
members does anybody wish to speak to
the amendment
councillor mr
um apologist chairman i didn't quite
catch what the amendment was could it
just be okay again please
right
okay
i'll read it out
and this is from the portfolio holder
for community safety
i fully support this motion but would
like to propose that
it be enhanced by not only noting its
contents but giving our ongoing
commitment to continue to work in
partnership with all responsible bodies
including the county-wide safety
advisory group
safer essex partners
and local community safety network
in order to achieve the objectives set
out in this motion
and report on the progress
to the
over new overview and scrutiny committee
at the time of the community safety
partnership annual update
is that correct council williams
okay does anybody else wish to speak to
the amendment
council ahoy
wrote something down in october and it's
it's been taking quite a long time to
come to full council i'm not going to
read out what i wrote then i don't think
we need to it seems like we're all
enforceable this is just purely to the
amendment is it yeah that's the case
okay to the amendment um
i i do support the amendment um
i
think
that adding the other organizations will
be helpful
and um i will support it
any anybody else wish to speak to the
amendment
okay okay members we now take a vote on
the amendment
those in favor please indicate
thank you members that is unanimous
that now becomes
part of the motion which is item 16.
any questions on the substantive motion
counselor mr high
around the white ribbon organisation
and the appointment of a
male counsellor
to
represent this council and to
to push forward this policy
is that
would that be an appointment to an
outside body
or would that be an appointment by a
portfolio holder
thank you
mr williams do you wish to respond to
that
sorry we can't hear you can you
yeah thank you as of yet that hasn't
been decided how we will take that board
but it will be considered thank you
thank you
okay anybody else
councilman
thank you mr chairman um
no decent or right-minded person
couldn't be appalled at the abort murder
of sarah everard last year
indeed
any murder
is absolutely tragic and awful
but that
reached new heights of awfulness
i'm particularly pleased that councillor
mrs newport
has brought this motion before us this
evening
it's a shame it's taken a few months but
we know the reasons why but it was very
important that we did take time out to
talk about these issues and what we can
do as an authority and i think it sets
out extremely well
by the various points
what we should be doing and i think it's
right and proper that we take time to
reflect on that
i am very proud of the fact that this
administration set one hundred thousand
pounds aside for community safety
initiatives in the district
a large part of that
is set aside for cctv
possibly in rady possibly in rockford
and that is an activity still ongoing
with the respective town and parish
councils
but in addition to that we wanted to
give the opportunity to all parishes to
have two and a half thousand pounds
match funded by themselves to make five
thousand pounds
for a community safety initiative within
their own parish
and i actually would urge all
councillors across the district bearing
in mind the parish
arrangements that we really press
to take advantage of that funding
i waste no time in any parish council
that i go to
in
reminding them that there is that money
and not only did we make the commitment
last financial year but we renewed it
this financial year so that we
accommodated the budget round of the
parish councils
so i think when i look at item 12
i really would urge all councillors to
impress on their parish councils to take
advantage of that offer
with regard to item 14
i have absolutely no problem with item
14
but i just wonder whether to strengthen
it bearing in mind it is the portfolio
holder with community safety
responsibilities that has the various
meetings with the
various authorities
county the police
and other agencies i really wonder
whether or not certainly i'm very happy
to endorse it and but i think we ought
to widen it to make sure that it is the
portfolio holder with responsibility for
community safety who reaches into areas
that i don't reach
is that person but i don't in any way
want to dilute
the the point of item 14 so i'm just
thinking of a practical arrangement
where the portfolio holder for
community safety
is engaged more than i am so i actually
want to strengthen it rather than weaken
it by saying that i'm opting out i'm
happy to be there
but it is that portfolio holder but
without any doubt totally support the
the motion before us tonight thank you
mr newport
thank you chairman um
i'm actually very happy to hear
councillor wootton um
refer back to the
community safety fund
um
because last week i contacted the
portfolio holder about that fund
and was told that the fund was closed
so
it's quite enlightening to hear that
it's open
and available
so all i would ask is that all
councillors are
uh given guidance on what that fund can
be used for again please
and
council newport can we keep keep it to
the motion concerned um if you wish to
talk to council wooden or
the portfolio holder outside of the
meeting i'm sure that they will uh um
advise you accordingly on the fund yeah
so
so the point is that as we're talking
about community safety is having
guidance how we can use that and just
one last point i'd like to make is that
i would also like to um i would support
the motion but also like to
give thanks to
um louisa moss who supported councillor
lisa newport with with this motion and
put a great deal of effort and work into
it thank you very much
thank you council report i'm sure that
is noted
okay
anybody else
counselor mrs mason i was just making
sure there's nobody else wanting to
sneak in before you
i'm not that
paranoid about being lost
but
thank you for the courtesy thank you mr
chairman
i welcome the support from the leader
for this important motion
and i also
am pleased that the portfolio holder
agrees that the safety of all residents
should be paramount
and indeed has taken the trouble to
strengthen the motion
this council should be proactive
rather than reactive
and i am pleased
that this has been demonstrated tonight
in supporting the substantive motion and
i welcome the support given
from everyone in this room thank you
counselor mrs newport do you wish to sum
up on this before we put it to vote
thank you chair not really a summing up
i'd just again like to thank louisa moss
for everything that she's done in
supporting and helping with this and i
would just like to make the councillors
aware that there are some white ribbons
on the tables where helen and veronica
are if
you want to collect one to support the
white ribbon
campaign thank you
okay members i'm very much hoping that
you don't require me to read all of the
items out again
and that you will be happy to accept the
vote on block including the amendment
amended item which i think makes it 16
in all
so our members happy for me to take that
on block
members uh in that case
uh those in favor please indicate
thank you members
that is unanimous thank you
okay
okay members just to remind you uh there
are some white ribbons i've been handed
one here at the table just as you leave
if you wish to collect one on your way
out
uh on that basis members i will close
the meeting at
20 37
thank you very much indeed members nice
to see you